hi my name is anish and I'm a junior
here at MIT and I'm working on building
provably correct peer-to-peer systems so
it turns out that peer-to-peer is an
incredibly useful paradigm for building
systems like for example fit point is a
peer-to-peer system and there are a
whole lot of things built in a
peer-to-peer manner um it turns out that
writing software is hard people make
mistakes and buggy systems lead to
problems so how can we be sure that our
peer-to-peer systems are correct because
they're so important right if something
happens bitcoin breaks and people lose
money that would be terrible so how do
we know that our software is correct
well we can use tests and we can write a
bunch of tests and check in without
prepares but that's not really great
because it doesn't cover all the corner
cases and we can't be super sure that
our code is pressed we can try proving
properties about our code on paper but
that isn't great either because it just
proves properties about the protocol and
it didn't prove that our implementation
is correct and so the way to solve this
problem is by using formal verification
and what that is is it's implementing
code in such a way that's it the
implementation of a program can be
checked against with specification in
such a way that the computer can
basically verify that it is correct and
so it provides an end-to-end guarantee
that a piece of code implements a
specification and I'm applying this
technique to peer-to-peer systems